but I think Darius by either K or
submission this thing's not going five
rounds you would have to give Darius a
title shot what are we doing here you
have to when it comes to giving Darius a
tire shot we have got to give him Top
Shot off this look at his resume dude
this be his ninth win in a row if you
beat Charles Oliver especially if he
gets to finish and Charles levere was
the king of the lightweight Division and
it's not like this is an old weather
Charles Oliveira y'all must have forgot
this dude has performed the knights
across the board his last loss was in
2017 before the mock Jeff title loss but
before that his last loss was in 2017
against Paul Felder my point of going
through Charles Oliveira's resume is if
Darius beats him which he will and he
gets a finish there is no Rhyme or
Reason why he doesn't fight for a title